[Musique]
bonjour manuel bonpard bONJ merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité politique
ce matin vous êtes député des bouches
duô coordinateur de la France insoumise
on va d'abord parler de ce discours
d'Emmanuel Macron hier à l'occasion des
65 ans de la Constitution Emmanuel
Macron qui a dit qu'il souhaitait
modifier la Constitution et notamment
élargir le champ du référendum et
faciliter le référendum d'initiative
partagée alors vous qui voulez donner la
parole au peuple vous allez voter cette
révision j'ai dit d'abord rien de
nouveau sur le soleil puisque je suis
pas un poisson rouge vous non plus
j'imagine et donc vous devez vous
rappeler que après la mobilisation des
gilets jaunes le président de la
République avait pris la parole pour
dire qu'il allait baisser à 1 million le
nombre de signatures nécessaires pour le
référendum d'initiative partagé c'était
il y a 4 ans depuis rien n'a bougé et
quand nous le groupe de la France à
soumise l'année dernière dans dans notre
niche parlementaire nous avons déposé
une proposition de loi pour concrétiser
cette promesse présidentielle les
députés macronistes ont voté contre donc
moi j'attends de voir la traduction
concrète des engagements du Président de
la République sur la facilitation du
référendum d'initiative partagé pour le
reste il semble qu'il veut ouvrir un
chantier sur l'extension du périmètre de
pardon c'est un peu compliqué ce qu'on
appelle l'article 11 de la Constitution
c'est-à-dire les référendum d'initiative
président
et moi sur ce sujet je suis hostile à
cette extension parce que je pense que
c'est une extension des pouvoirs du
Président de la République lui-même donc
en réalité derrière l'apparence de
vouloir donner davantage la parole au
peuple on augmente les pouvoirs du
Président de la République puisqu'on lui
permet de convoquer davantage de de de
référendum moi je suis pour des
référendum d'initiative citoyennes et
pas des référendum d'initiative
présidentiell oui mais est-ce que du
coup ça va pas empêcher de donner plus
la parole au peuple sur certains sujets
il est restreint ce champ de l'article
vous vous dites il faut donner plus la
parole au peup est-ce que là c'est pas
contradictoire de dire non on veut pas
élargir l'article 11 non je pense que
pour donner davantage la parole au
peuple il faut faire en sorte que le
peuple puisse obtenir des référendum et
donc c'est la proposition de référendum
d'initiative citoyenne qui a été une des
des fortes mobilisation notamment et
revendication pendant le le mouvement
des gilets jeunes que nous aussi nous
avons porté à plusieurs reprises à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui pour
l'instant a toujours été rejeté donc il
faut un référendum d'initiative
citoyenne pourquoi pas étendre le
référendum d' initiative partagé mais ça
le président de la République on a déjà
parlé il y a 4 ans et n'a pas bougé sur
ce sujet et de manière plus générale je
trouve que dans son intervention hier il
a cherché surtout à essayer de protéger
cette 5è République que je conteste on
va venir mais juste sur sur le sur le
référendum il a mis en garde aussi
contre la concurrence des légitimité
entre le vote du Parlement et entre ce
qui serait soumis au référendum vous
vous êtes député est-ce que vous êtes
sensible à ça comment on fait pour que
les les deux s'g il y a pas deux
légitimité il y en a qu'une seule c'est
la légitimité issu du peuple et elle pe
vous aussi vous êtes issu du peuple bien
sûr elle peut s'exprimer de différentes
manières elle peut s'exprimer à travers
ses représentants à l'Assemblée
nationale et elle peut s'exprimer à
travers un référendum mais ce qui a la
légitimité la plus puissante c'est quand
c'est le peuple qui vote directement pas
à travers ses représentants donc j'ai
bien compris pourquoi le président de la
République il disait ça il disait ça
parce que nous proposons depuis
plusieurs mois qu'il puisse y avoir un
référendum sur la retraite à 64 ans et
il voulait écarter cette possibilité
pour écarter cette possibilité il essaie
de nous faire croire que un texte qui
serait passé en force à l'Assemblée
nationale par le recours à l'article 493
de la Constitution ne pourrait plus être
en quelque sorte battu par un référendum
bon d'AC ave il y a un délai d'un an il
faut revoir ce délai pour vous moi moi
je pense que le référendum peut être
précisément un moyen de de de trancher
quand il y a des des des des un défaut
de légitimité d'un texte parce que il a
pas pu être voté à l' donc de passer au
dessus du Parlement est-ce que vous
affaiblissez pas le rôle des représent
de la nation a enfin excusez-moi c'est
une plaisanterie ce qui a affaibli le
rôle des représentants de la nation
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas pu voter sur ce
texte donc moi je veux bien qu'on
m'explique maintenant que la procédure
parlementaire aurait été parfaite et que
en proposant un référendum sur ce sujet
on vient empiéter sur la souveraineté
des députés mais franchement ça va
convaincre personne parce que en
l'occurrence sur ce texte il y avait une
majorité de députés pour rejeter la
retraite à 64 ans et c'est précisément
parce qu'il y avait une majorité de
députés pour rejeter ce texte que le
Président de la République a eu recours
à l'article 493 de la Constitution donc
si on veut défendre la souveraineté du
peuple on fait en sorte que quand il y a
un problème sur un texte de loi parce
que il y a une un conflit entre ce que
pense le président de la République et
ce que pense une grande partie de la
population on permet à la population de
dénouer ce conflit démocratiquement et
ça c'est l'objectif du référendum avec
un risque d'instabilité ça veut dire que
si le Parlement n'arrive pas à voter on
va on va vers le référendum bah pourquoi
pas il y a je je pense que c'est vous
savez gouverner c'est une pratique et
vous vous pouvez toujours utiliser les
pires travers de la 5 ré parement sert
plus à rien soit il est d'accord il
enregistre les texes soit il est pas
d'accord et on passe par rferindom non
le Parlement il a la possibilité de se
prononcer de s'exprimer sur beaucoup de
textes de loi mais vous pouvez entendre
que quand un on est dans une situation
avec un conflit social comme celui qu'on
a connu cette année qu'il y a
manifestement une crispation sur un
texte de loi normalement la
responsabilité de quelqu'un qui gouverne
c'est pas de passer en force et de créer
cette fracture c'est de dire bon j'ai
pas réussi à à convaincre je laisse les
Françaises et les Français trancher s'il
l'avait fait je pense qu'on en serait
pas là aujourd'hui sur l'IVG il veut que
le droit à l'avortement soit inscrit
dans la Constitution dès que possible
là-dessus vous êtes satisfait ah ben moi
je suis pour que le droit à la
constitution puisse être le droit à
l'avortement pardon puisse être inscrit
dans la Constitution le plus rapidement
possible mais franchement le président
de la République est un hypocrite parce
que si vraiment il souhaite que le droit
à l'IVG soit inscrit dans la
Constitution le plus rapidement possible
il faut que lui prenne l'initiative d'un
projet de loi gouver gouvernemental lui
ou son gouvernement qui pourrait ensuite
être voté dans les mêmes termes au Sénat
et à l'Assemblée nationale et ensuite
passer par le Congrès aujourd'hui vous
avez un texte que nous avons déposé nous
les on soumis dans notre niche
parlementaire la semaine l'année
dernière qui a été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale pour inscrire le droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution le texte est venu
ici au Sénat il a été modifié il a été
adopté par le Sénat maintenant il y a
deux options elle vous convient la
modification du Sénat c'est la liberté
de recourir à l'AV c'est pas la moi
c'est pas la formule que que nous av
vous prê si ça permet l'incription dans
la si à la fin c'est la seule qui permet
que que que que que le droit à l'IVG
soit inscrit dans la Constitution bon ça
sera pas aussi satisfaisant que si
c'était la proposition initiale que nous
avons formulé mais si ça permet
d'avancer avançons mais alors c'est le
président de la République qui a la main
pour avancer c'est pas nous donc c'est
facile de dire je suis pour mais quand
après vous faites rien ça fait un an
qu'il aurait pu déposer un projet de loi
constitutionnel sur ce sujet tout tout
le monde n'attend que lui donc qu'il le
fasse un dernier mot sur ce discours il
a parlé de décentralisation il veut une
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation et
il a notamment parlé de la Corse il
s'est redit prêt à accorder une forme
d'autonomie à la Corse vous la voterez
vous euh bah en tout cas moi je suis
favorable à ce que on on on permette à à
la à la Corse de pouvoir avoir une
autonomie dans le cadre de la
Constitution aujourd'hui maintenant il
faudra voir quelle forme elle prend pour
l'instant on a peu de détails sur ce que
le président de la République est est
Fages rouges euh moi j'ai surtout oui
j'ai des lignes rouges notamment il y a
des demandes de de de droit à ce qu'on a
appelle la différenciation c'est-à-dire
pouvoir avoir des des des propositions
de loi différentes bon ça doit se
discuter mais ce droit à la
différenciation ne peut pas être
utiliser par exemple pour avoir un droit
social qui serait un droit social moins
favorable en Corse que ce qu'on pourrait
observer ailleurs s'il s'agit de dire
que cette différenciation elle permet
d'être dans le mieuxdant social
c'est-à-dire d'avoir des des par exemple
un droit social qui soit plus avantageux
pourquoi pas si ça permet en quelque
sorte une sorte de concurrence régionale
sur les droits sociaux j'y serai
totalement opposé autre sujet manuel
bonpard Élisabeth borne réunit
aujourd'hui à matinon un conseil
national de la refondation sur les
émeutes est-ce que vous irez euh non
d'abord parce que ce ce gadget du
Conseil national de la refondation est
boycotté à peu près par tout le monde
les organisations syndicales les
opposition parce que si on veut discuter
d'un sujet moi je veux bien discuter de
ce sujet il y a une Assemblée nationale
il y a un sénat et je pense que les
Français et les organisations politiques
aussi d'ailleurs en ont assez de ces
tentativ permanente de tournement du
débat parlementaire par le Président de
la République et la première ministre
donc moi je suis d'accord pour discuter
de ce sujet mais pour
ça table pour discuter avant de faire
des propositions fin octobre ah elle
veut mettre tout le monde autour de la
table pour discuter avant de faire des
propositions fin octobre c'est très
intéressant mais ça vous convent pas
mais vous attendez quoi comme mesure
puisqu'elle doit faire des annonces
octobre qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'elle
doit dire et j'en ai parlé j'étais à la
rencontre fameuse rencontre organisée
par le Président de la République que je
trouve stupéfiant sur ce sujet c'est
qu'on nous on prétend vouloir apporter
des réponses à aux événements qui se
sont déroulés au mois de juin au mois de
juillet dernier en oubliant le fait
générateur qu'est-ce qui a produit ces
événements ce qui a produit ces
événements c'est le meurtre par un
policier d'un jeune homme
Naël qui a été tué et c'est ça qui a
déclochché une vague de colère et
d'indignation bien sûr cette vague de
colère et d'indignation elle s'est elle
a exprimé aussi de le résultat de
politique depuis des années et des
années de relégation des quartiers
populaires de ce pays donc bien sûr on
peut apporter des réponses à cette
situation mais on peut pas oublier le
fait générateur quand même donc si vous
voulez d'abord apporter une réponse à ce
qui s'est passé vous devez commencer par
vous attaquer au problème des relations
entre la police et une partie de la
population et vous me demandez des
propositions je vais vous en donner
revenir sur la loi de 2017 qui a permis
de faciliter l'usage des armes suite à
des à des refus d'obtempérés depuis
cette loi le nombre de personnes mortes
suite à des refus d'obtempérés a
augmenté de 500 % donc c'est pas
possible mais pour vous c'est uniquement
là-dessus qu'il faut faire des
proposition uniquement pas uniquement
mais au moins un peu là-dessus parce que
le président de républque nen parle
pasth ellisabeth borne elle veut
aujourd'hui parler de la prévention
d'intélinquance du soutien aux familles
du profil des ametiers de la
responsabilité parentale pour vous c'est
des thèmes qu'il faut pas aborder non on
peut parler de tout mais on peut pas
parler de tout sauf du fait générateur
des événements maintenant si vous voulez
parler du reste parlons du reste cette
campagne de stigmatisation à l'égard des
parents elle est insupportable vous
parlez de de de de familles qui sont
souvent dans des situations sociales
extrêmement difficiles à Nanterre qui
est la la la cité Pablo Picasso à nterre
il y a 30 % des familles qui sont
monoparentales il y en a 50 % qui vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté dans les
quartiers populaires de ce pays le taux
de pauvreté est trois fois plus
important que dans la moyenne de de de
de dans le reste de la du pays bon si
vous voulez apporter des réponses à ces
situations c'est nécessairement des
réponses aux difficultés sociales on
nous dit oui mais il y a des enfants qui
s'occupent mal de leurs enfants bah
souvent la
des parents qui s'occupent mal de les
enfants souvent c'est des gens qui
travaillent t le matin c'est pas facile
bon et même imaginons que ça existe il y
a aujourd'hui des mesures
d'accompagnement à l'éducation qui sont
prévues par la justice tous les
spécialistes vous disent qu'elles ne
sont pas suivies des faits parce que les
associations qui sont censées les
prendre en charge ont été sous-financé
ces dernières années donc voilà moi je
veux bien qu'on discute de ces sujets
mais d'abord sans oublier le fait
générateur deuxièmement en arrêtant de
culpabiliser les parents qui sont pas
responsables de ces difficultés parce
que c'est difficile d'être parents et tr
trement en mettant les moyens
nécessaires pour faire en sorte que des
mesures d'accompagnement puissent
effectivement être effectives on va
parler de ce qui va se passer à
l'Assemblée la semaine prochaine jeudi
prochain notamment aura lieu la niche du
rassemblement national c'est le moment
où les groupes peuvent déposer et
examiner leur textte avec notamment un
texte sur la souffrance des femmes
victime d'endométriose vous le voterez
alors d'abord je veux dire sur ce sujet
que c'est dans une niche parlementaire
de la France insoumise que la première
fois sous l'initiative de nos députés de
clémentinetin de math pano nous avions
fait voter une résolution sur cette
question là de l'endométriose pour le
reste j'ai entendu avant la niche du
rassemblement national que le
gouvernement avait l'intention de
prendre des mesures par décret donc il
reste peu de temps c'est le 12 octobre
bah on verra s'il le fait ou pas et s'il
le fait pas vous voterez le texte du RN
ou pas bah je verrai ce qu'il y a dans
le texte du RN en dernier lieu mais euh
de manière général je crois vousz V il
été examiné en commission oui mais vous
savez les textes ils peuvent bouger ils
peuvent être amendés on verra pour
l'instant le gouvernement a dit qu'il
allait prendre des des des des mesures
donc j'attends de voir s'il va prendre
effectivement ses mesures ou pas
sinon bah sinon ça dépend ce qu'il y a
dans le texte je crois que je vous ai
répondu mais ça vous ça vous pourriez
voter même si ça vient du rassemblement
national de manière générale euh les
propositions du rassemblement national
sont des propositions que nous
combattons donc normalement nous ne même
quand c'est des sujets sur lesquels vous
êtes d'accord oui mais c'est pas parce
que c'est des sujets sur lesquels on est
d'accord que les propositions et les
modalités de réponse qui sont proposées
sont forcément des modalités de réponse
sur lesquelles nous sommes d'accord par
exemple dans la même niche du
rassemblement national il y a une
proposition de loi sur la question des
prix de l'énergie bon il se trouve que
en ce moment suite à un vote à
l'assemblée et un vote au Sénat il y a
une autre proposition sur les prix de
l'énergie qui est beaucoup plus
favorable que celle du rassemblement
national donc les coups de communication
du rassemblement national qui se
traduisent par le fait d'affaiblir des
mesures que nous avons réussi à voter à
l'Assemblée nationale je vais pas y
participer le projet de loi pour avancer
sur les négociation commerciale plutôt
au lieu de du mois de mars pour les
avancés plutôt dans l'année pour
permettre plus rapidement la baisse des
prix dans l'alimentaire sera débattu à
partir de lundi par les députés quelle
sera votre position bah je je je trouve
que c'est une une fumisterie
euh le les marges de l'industrie
agroalimentaire elles ont augmenté de 70
% depuis 2 ans dans le même temps les
prix de l'agroalimentaire ont augmenté
de 21 %. donc le problème c'est pas
d'avancer la date des négociations ou de
demander plus gentiment à des
industriels le problème c'est de les
contraindre donc si vous voulez
effectivement apporter une réponse à une
situation qui est extrêmement difficile
je voudrais quand même vous dire que
hier à l'Assemblée nationale nous avons
auditionn les associations de solidarité
alimentaire les restos du cœur nous
disent que pour la première fois de son
histoire au mois de novembre il commence
à refuser des bénéficiaires si vous
voulez faire en sorte d'apporter une
réponse vous devez avoir des mesures
contraignantes pas des mesures où on va
demander gentiment à des industriels qui
en ont rien à faire des demandes qu'on
leur fait de baisser les prix ou
d'encadrer leur marge donc moi je suis
favorable à des mesures de blemmanuel
Macon non Emmanuel Macron il s'attaque
aux marges en demandant gentiment aux
industriels s'il vous plaît messieurs et
mesdames de baisser vos marges mais ça
ne marche pas ça ne fonctionne pas et
Emmanuel Macron il refuse de faire la
seule chose dont il a le pouvoir c'est
d'avoir des mesures de blocage donc il
faut bloquer les prix sur un produit de
première un paquet un panier de produits
de première nécessité je voudrais quand
même vous dire que tout le monde nous
dit c'est pas possible c'est des mesures
qui existent sur l'île de la Réunion par
exemple où chaque année vous identifiez
un certain nombre de produits et il y a
des prix qui sont des prix fixés il faut
faire la même chose sur le carburant
parce que là aussi les raffineurs ont vu
leur marge augmenter multiplié par 5
depuis 6 mois donc que tous les gens qui
nous écoutent comprennent que quand on
leur dit mais l'inflation on peut rien y
faire mais l'inflation elle n'a pas des
causes naturelles hein l'inflation elle
est est dû au fait le Fond Monétaire
International dit à l'échelle mondiale
l'inflation est dû pour moitié à
l'augmentation des profits des grandes
entreprises donc vous voterez pas le
texte donc non je ne voterai pas le
texte et je fais des propositions
alternatives qui sont des mesures de
blocage des prix de blocage des marges
d'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation pour faire en sorte que
quand les prix augmentent les salaires
augmentent d'autant pour faire en sorte
que les gens puissent enfin vivre
dignement dans ce pays on va parler de
la nup et des différentes élections
d'abord les sénatorial qui ont donc eu
lieu dimanche dernier socialiste
communiste écologiste avaient conclu des
accords en vous écartant résultat le
nombre de sénateurs de gauche a augmenté
est-ce que ça veut dire que la gauche
peut être victorieuse sans vous le le le
nombre de sénateurs de gauche a augmenté
je crois qu'il est de 99 si j'ai bien
compris les les les derniers calculs le
fait que les les socialistes les
communistes les écologistes a décidé
d'exclure les insoumis il suffit de
regarder les résultats a fait perdre à
laanupes une dizaine de sièges c'est pas
ce qu'ils disent he bah ils peuvent ne
pas le dire mais quand dans le
département des Hautes scènes il y a un
siège qui est perdu à trois voix euh et
que il y a une liste insoumise qui en
fait quasiment 100 vous pouvez
considérer que ce siège n'aurait pas pu
être gagné mais si il aurait pu être
gagné ouis mais eux ils vous disent à
l'inverse que si vous aviez pas présenté
des candidats partout contre eux la
gauche sénatoriale aurait fait encore
plus donc en fait il fallait tout
simplement qu'on passe notre tour à
cette élection c'est ça écoutez c'est
pas sérieux si enfin je veux dire
parilleur c'est contradictoire soit
c'est pas vrai on n pas fait perdre de
siège soit le fait qu'on est bon donc il
faut faut être raisonnable la vérité
c'est que si comme nous l'avions proposé
nous avions eu un accord national de
l'anups permettant de faire en sorte que
tout toutes les composantes de l'anupes
soient ensemble sur des listes partout
en France nous aurions eu une dizaine de
sièges supplémentaires donc je pense que
ceux qui ont pris la responsabilité de
nous exclure de ces listes on fait du
mal à la gauche dans son ensemble
puisque nous aurions pu être sans doute
110 sénateurs ici au Sénat et donc je
pense qu'ils ont une très lourde
responsabilité d'abord ils ont affaibli
laanupess et en plus ils ont affaibli le
nombre de représentants de la gauche au
Sénat alors il en sera de même aux
européennes puisque Olivier fort a écrit
une lettre lundi soir à tous les
représentants de la nu pour mettre fin
au f fa suspendre s acte le fait qu'il y
aura pas de list communes aux
européennes c'est un échec pour vous
c'est un échec pour
l'anupes et c'est un échec et un
problème pour le pays mais moi je me
résigne pas à cette à cette situation
toujours pas non ti vous croyez encore à
une liste commune je dis voilà ce que je
vous dis les appareils socialistes
communistes écologistes ne veulent pas
d'une liste commune de la nupè aux
élections européennes pourtant il y a un
programme pour le faire les jeunes de
l'anupes ont travaillé à un programme
commun tout le monde reconnaît que ce
programme est un programme de qualité
donc il y a pas de divergence
programmatique insurmontable donc si les
appareils ne veulent pas l'Union moi je
dis aux électrices et aux électeurs
c'est à vous de faire l'union vous avez
la possib comment c'estàd que là ils
vont avoir est-ce qu'il aura est-ce que
déjà mais est-ce qu'il y aura il y aura
une liste de la France en son il y aura
une liste qui portera le programme de la
nupès aux élections européenes donc
c'estàdire vous vous allez présenter une
liste étiqueté nupes on por non on
portera le programme qui est le
programme sur lequel les organisations
de jeunesse de l' laanupes se sont mis
d'accord ce programme existe nous
pourrions le porter tous ensemble dans
cette élection mais j'ai j'ai les les
les communistes les écologistes les
socialistes ne le veulent pas donc moi
je dis à tous ceux qui veulent venir le
porter avec nous venez on va faire une
liste de d'union populaire et puis les
électrices et les électeurs bah ils
auront la possibilité de faire l'union
en seroupant autour de cette liste B
pour l'instant je lance un appel je dis
à tous ceux qui veulent venir euh faire
cette liste avec nous cette liste
d'union cette liste de rassemblement
venez la faire avec nous elle serapporté
par quelqu'un de la France ins on verra
tout est ouvert tout est discutable là
vous allezriber vous attribuer laanupes
alors que les trois autres ont dit je
m'attribu rien madame je fais référence
à un programme qui est le programme de
l'anupes j'ai encore le droit dans une
élection de pouvoir porter le programme
de notre choix donc nous avons nous
souhaitons porter le
programme travailler avec notamment les
jeunes de laanups puisque ils ont fait
la démonstration qu'il y a un programme
commun possible pour le reste les les
appareils ne le veulent pas le refuseent
se mettre en dehors de l'Union qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que je fasse d'autre que
cela si change d'avis très bien moi j'en
serais très heureux il vous propose une
réunion Oliv fort il dit il faut
permettre de rendre à nouveau possible
un dialogue serein vous acceptez cette
réunion mais une réunion pourquoi pour r
possible un dialogue serein moi je suis
prêt à participer à une réunion comme
l'ont proposé les jeunes de l'anupes
pour discuter du programme commun que
nous pourrions porter ensemble aux éles
pas une réunion avec Olivier fort
marineous marine tdelier Fabien Roussell
veulent participer à une réunion sur le
programme des prochaines élections
européennes je suis tout à fait
favorable pour y participer il compris
avec Fabien Roussel bah Fabien Roussell
je crois avoir entendu clairement euh
que il se mettait à distance de l'anupes
il me semble que une ch c'est pas ce qu'
dit non non c'est ce qu'il dit lui enfin
écoutez quand vous dites que vous ne
vous retrouvez dit qu'il faut la
refonder il dit attendez attendez madame
la nupes c'est c'est une coalition que
nous avons constitué il y a un an qui a
un programme partagé de 650 mesures qui
a présenté des candidatures ensemble aux
élections législatives Fabien Roussel
nous dit je ne me retrouve pas dans ce
programme Fabien Rousel nous dit je ne
suis pas favorable à une à des
candidatures communes aux sénatoriales
pas favorable à des candidatures
communes aux européennes pas favorable à
des candidatures communes municipales
pas favorable à des candidatures
communes au présidentielles parce qu'il
faut qu'au premier tour on puisse
présenter nos propres candidatures et
nos propres propositions donc il n'est
pas favorable non plus à des
candidatures communes aux prochaines
élections législatives donc moi je veux
bien que ça s'appelle rester dans
l'anupes mais quand vous êtes d'accord
ni avec le programme ni avec le fait de
présenter des candidatures ensemble ce
n'est pas le cas donc moi au bout d'un
moment je prend acte de cette situation
je la regrette je la déplore je pense
que l'anupè c'est le chemin le plus
court pour pouvoir gagner je pense qu'on
a besoin de cette unité et ce
rassemblement pour faire en sorte que
les Français qui cherchent une
alternative à Emmanuel Macron et une
autre solution possible que celle de
l'extrême droite mais maintenant je peux
pas forcer les gens donc s'ils veulent
partir tout seul dans leur coin ils
partiront tout seul dans leur coin mais
nous on continuera à avancer avec tous
ceux qui veulent avancer dans une
démarche de rassemblement autour du
programme de la nuupes un dernier mot
sur votre parti manuel bpard il y a un
complément d'enquête sur France 2 qui
sera diffusé ce soir une enquête sur
sopia Chikirou qui est député à fi de
Paris proche de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur
son rôle pendant les campagnes de 2017
et 2022 et également sur sa personnalité
d'abord vous regarderez ce complément
d'enquête non moi j'ai il y a le match
de l'Olympique de Marseille je pense ça
sera plus intéressant ce soir vous vous
regarderez pas du tout non selon le
journal Le Monde sopia Chikirou elle
devrait être prochainement entendue en
vue d'une mise en examen pour
escroquerer aggraver des soupçons de
surfacturation de sa société médiascope
à la France insoumise lors de la
campagne 2017 pe sur elle elle se serait
versé à elle-même c'est ce que dit le
journal la quasi totalité des bénéfices
de la campagne de 2017 en prime et en
dividende qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça est-ce que vous souhaitez la
transparence que c'est complètement faux
et la transparence elle existe déjà
puisque sopia Chikirou est député elle a
donc déposé un dossier auprès de la
Haute Autorité de la transparence et de
la vie publique dans lequel ses revenus
et ses rémunérations sont présentes et
le journal Le Monde aurait pu faire son
travail avant d'écrire des fausses
informations puisque Sofia Chikirou vous
pouvez regarder les chiffres de 2017 a
touché entre 4000 et 4500 € par mois
pendant la campagne présidentielle bon
euh dans le même temps dans le même
temps parce que quand même juste pour
qu'on on ait des chiffre un peu comparés
dans le même temps monsieur gveau qui
était porte-parole d'Emmanuel Macron
touchit 8000 € par mois non mais juste
pour que tout le monde le sache voilà
donc il faut arrêter les fausses
informations je j'invite les
journalistes à faire leur travail de
vérification de manière sérieuse par
exemple la même journaliste du Monde
explique que mathil pano qui est la
présidente de mon groupe parlementaire a
été mise en examen c'est complètement
faux donc juste j'ai compris qu'il y
avait une volonté de nuire mais au moins
s'il vous plaî au moins s'il vous plaît
faites-le proprement là rien a rien
n'est vrai dans cet article il est
également dit il est également dit
qu'elle aurait payé des salariés et des
stagiaires qu'elle les aurait souspayé
en tout cas au-dessous du niveau de
salaire pour les les compétences madame
on a été on a subi il y a 5 ans 12
perquisitions depuis 5 ans il y a rien
de nouveau aucune nouvelle information
le journal Le Monde dit il y aurait sans
doute peut-être une mise en examen je
sais pas comment ils le savent parce
parce que en tout cas aucun d'entre nous
qui avont été mis en cause dans cette
affaire n'a été informé de ça donc je je
je je vous dis que pas
CIS n pasination je n'ai pas
d'information sur ce sujet il n'y a eu
aucune surfacturation dans cette
campagne la campagne de on parle de la
campagne de Jean menchan de 2017 he pour
que les les gens qui nous écoutent
comprennent cette campagne est celle qui
a coûté la moins cher de ceux de
l'ensemble des candidats on nous dit oui
c'était une manière de se faire une une
de une trésorerie pour ensuite mais il
restait de mémoire 8000 € à la fin de la
campagne sur ceux qu'on accuse de faire
une caisse écoutez tout ça n'est pas
sérieux parce que selon l'article elle
se serait versé le Surp en selon
l'article mais selon l'article de rien
du tout madame puisque les comme je
vouslaai dit en réponse à ma première
question les rémunérations de sopia
chquiro elles sont publiques elles sont
publiques donc j'invite les journalistes
qui font ce travail à aller sur le site
de la Haute Autorité de la transparence
et de la vie publique je les aide
www.hat vp.fr ensuite vous avez un
bandeau vous pouvez faire recherche vous
tapez sopia chikiro vous allez tomber
sur un tableau où elle déclare
l'ensemble de ses revenus donc je sais
pas faites votre travail sérieusement
s'il vous plaît messieur mesames les
journalist il y a aucune contestation de
son rôle et de ses pratiques au sein de
la France insoumise à sopia chikiron euh
en tout cas moi je ne conteste pas son
rôle et ses pratiques ça a été une une
une non non vous n'avez jamais entendu
ça vous êtes coordinateur du par ça été
un maillon très important de des
campagnes présidentielles parce que j'ai
bien compris avec beaucoup de sexisme
d'ailleurs qu'on essae de dénoncer comme
on l'a fait à mathil Panau comme on l'a
fait à à Rachel kké on essaie de de
dénoncer des femmes qui ont un caractère
qui ont une influence très importante
dans la France souise je trouvais ça
assez
oui oui il y a du sexisme par je je ne
dis pas que c'est juste parce que c'est
une face mais il y a une manière de
décrire j'ai vu que la mathil pano a
fait l'objet d'un article dans Le
Parisien dimanche une manière de décrire
les les les les femmes engagées à la
France insoumise qui ont du caractère
qui se laissent pas marcher sur les
pieds d'une manière extrêmement
désagréable
donc après mais mais il y a
manifestement une volonté de nuir ça
j'ai bien compris puisque une telle
cabale médiatique organisé avec des
articles qui sortent tous en même temps
mais j'en ai vu d'autres vous voyez donc
il y a 3 mois c'était quelqu'un d'autre
il y a 3 mois ça sera quelqu'un d'autre
amusez-vous bien faites-vous plaisir
dans cette cabale nous en tout cas on
continue à s'occuper des problèmes du
pays parce que le pays il a des grosses
difficultés des gros problèmes le reste
j'ai l'impression que ça amuse quelques
journalistes merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité on passe au
club de territoire